je suis Muriel je suis au rsa depuis
plus d'un an et je souhaite travailler
dans le service à la personne je décide
de me former au centre de formation des
apprentis où je découvre le nouveau
dispositif r+, la location d'insertion
et de retour à l'emploi je signe donc un
contrat de formation de 3 mois et avec
mon conseiller d'insertion du
département je signe un contrat r+,
pendant ma formation R+ permet le
maintien de mes allocations et s'ajoute
à mes revenus après ma formation j'ai
décroché un poste à plein temps et mon
diplôme est une sécurité pour l'avenir
faire plus l'activité en toute sécurité
plus d'informations sur
www.departement974.fr